this is jezreel crater
today it is a hostile landscape too
bitterly cold and dry
for any living thing to survive a few
billion years ago however
jezreel might have looked similar to
earth's own lake salda
in turkey back then mars owned a thicker
atmosphere
it warmed the planet enough for water to
flow and lakes to form in craters like
jezreel
such conditions could have supported the
beginnings of life
but did this warm environment last long
enough to foster microbes
and why did mars change so drastically
nasa's latest mars rover perseverance
will investigate these questions
by collecting martian rock and soil
samples that may one day
return to earth on the outside
perseverance might look familiar the
rover's design
borrows much from its older sibling
curiosity
but on the inside perseverance holds
something new
the sample caching system this
sophisticated machine
will drill into the martian surface and
remove
image and store chalk sized cores of
rock and soil
eventually the rover will cash more than
30 cores
for a future mission to pick up and send
to earth for intensive study
we can't learn much from these cores
until they make their journey home
but perseverance has more than one trick
up its sleeve
the rover is outfitted with tools to
discern the chemical makeup of rocks and
soil
by mapping the distribution of organic
molecules in a rock
these tools could help scientists
differentiate between organic debris
from meteorite impacts
and the remains of microbial life
perseverance will spend its first two
years exploring jezreel and collecting
samples on a meandering path from lake
bed to shore
the rover's primary mission is to seek
signs of past life
but researchers will also use the data
to investigate the geologic and climatic
history of mars
beginning its journey on the dark crater
floor perseverance will likely find
a volcanic landscape frozen in time
if the surface is in fact fossilized
lava flow
researchers may discern the lake's age
thanks to radiometric
dating next the rover should encounter
fine-grained clay at the edge of the
delta which sits at the mouth of an
ancient river that fed into the lake
on earth these clays often preserve
biosignatures
so here perseverance will look for
organic compounds that could betray the
existence
of past microorganisms continuing its
quest for ancient life
the rover will traverse rough sandstone
the grains of this sandstone might be
billions of years old having flowed down
river from some of the oldest terrain on
mars
if this is the case researchers could
study the magnetic signatures of these
early rocks to unveil the history of the
martian magnetic field
one theory suggests that the field
shielded a thick atmospheric blanket
that once warmed the red planet
and when the field failed the atmosphere
dissipated and the climate changed
to culminate its mission the rover will
seek the carbonate-rich shores of the
ancient lake
these limestone-like carbonates are
known on earth to preserve stromatolites
mounds formed by bacterial growth thus
this is an ideal place to look for such
geologic time capsules of past life
scientists are also interested in these
minerals because they're scarce
on the surface of mars despite an
atmosphere that today
is 95 carbon dioxide studying these
rocks
could reshape our limited understanding
of the martian carbon cycle perseverance
is the first mars rover designed to seek
signs of ancient life
but that's not the missions only first
one instrument
will record sound on the martian surface
for the very first time
another the ingenuity helicopter will
attempt to demonstrate the first powered
flight on another planet
a challenging feat since the martian
atmosphere is 100 times thinner
than earth's if successful ingenuity
could pave the way for future flight
driven exploration
on the red planet more than 50 years ago
humans retrieved rocks and soil from the
moon for the very first
time these samples completely reshaped
our understanding of the moon's
formation
and continue to be studied today we can
only begin to imagine what similar
samples from mars
might teach us about the red planet our
solar system
and perhaps life itself
[Music]
[Music]
you